thank you very much it's uh great to be
here on this occasion you know I'm here
year after year and this is certainly
the happiest restoration weekend I've
been to
and very happy to say we won't have
chick Nixon to kick around
anymore come on the uh fact is that
Hillary Clinton's defeat is is a very
very serious Victory not only for the
Second Amendment but for the first and
this is something that has been
insufficiently appreciated in all the
commentary before the election and after
Donald Trump of course he went after her
many times saying Hillary Clinton is
against the Second Amendment he's she's
going to stop the uh uh sale of lawful
Weaponry in every way she possibly can
but he never spoke about the threat that
she posed to the First Amendment and
that is an ongoing threat and a still
existing threat and it's very important
to bear that in mind because even though
she was
defeated this threat has not gone away
the left is in a full court press and a
yearslong effort to destroy the First
Amendment and essentially to criminalize
any point of view that is not their
own and this is a struggle that they are
going to
continue now there are many many facets
of this one is of course the most
notable one I should say is the
organization of Islamic cooperation
which is 57 Muslim governments around
the world 56 States and the Palestinian
Authority the largest voting block at
the United Nations and they of course
for years now since the publication of
the Danish cartoons of Muhammad in 2006
they have been working to restrict the
freedom of speech and to compel western
states to restrict the freedom of speech
at the UN I know a lot of you are
familiar with that effort and that they
have under the guise of what they call
incitement to religious hatred they're
trying to compel Western governments to
criminalize essentially criticism of
Islam obviously when you talk about
incitement to religious hatred any kind
of incitement unless it's absolutely
direct and explicit is a subjective
judgment in the first place secondly
nobody cares when people put crucifixes
in jars of urine or mock Israel and
Judaism nobody cares about those things
they only care about religious hatred in
an Islamic context and the most
Insidious aspect of this endeavor this
initiative is of course that any honest
discussion of how Islamic jihadis use
the texts and teachings of Islam to
justify violence is classified
explicitly by the OIC as incitement to
religious ha
hatred so what they want to do is
criminalize any discussion of the
motivating ideology behind Jihad
terrorism and the goal of that of course
is to enable Jihad terrorists to advance
unopposed and
unimpeded now this has been going on for
years it's been going on since the Bush
Administration and the Bush
Administration at the UN vetoed these
initiatives every year but then of
course came Barack Hussein Obama
and this twice the United States signed
on to these initiatives and actually
co-sponsored one with Egypt in 2009 and
then even more notoriously signed on to
resolution 1618 of the UN Human Rights
Council which once again called upon UN
member States to criminalize incitement
to religious hatred and it had a little
asterisk going to a footnote explaining
that yes the UN understood that there
were certain countries that had
protection for the freedom of speech and
they would have to devise other ways to
implement this initiative that would not
collide with their
laws now that was the most Insidious
aspect of the whole thing and Hillary
Clinton explained what it was all about
not long after that in a speech in
Istanbul to the
OIC and she said and I know many of you
have heard this quote many of you are
very well aware of what she said in this
but I think that not many of you are
aware of exactly how this initiative is
proceeding what she said of course was
that we value the freedom of expression
which she doesn't but she said that she
did and that in light of protecting the
freedom of expression as well as
protecting religious
sensibilities in order to compel people
not to do what we don't want them to do
we have to resort to she said
old-fashioned techniques of peer
pressure and
shaming old-fashioned techniques of peer
pressure and shaming remember when she
said
that this is exactly how the Western
media has
proceeded in order essentially not to
criminalize but to rule out of accept
the realm of acceptable discourse any
honest discussion of these issues what
happened to Oleg in his presentation
just now is actually a case in point
he's not facing a felony charge for
using the wrong kind of glue come on we
weren't born yesterday it we know that
if he had been put putting up posters
for the Palestinians there would have
been no problem at George Mason
University but because he was putting up
pro-israel posters from the David
harwitz Freedom Center suddenly all
these rules about glue kick in and he
goes to
jail now what it is is peer pressure and
shaming is essentially a
strategy that makes it impossible for us
to discuss these matters because of
exactly that kind of bias and favoritism
only only one point of view is
acceptable and any other point of
view is something that we're going to be
shamed out of you can just think about
how many times Trump's supporters were
mocked ridiculed I read a piece by Paul
Burman from December 2015 I reread it a
few months ago I recommend that you find
it and read it it was in tablet
magazine and he explains how Trump gives
his uh poorly educated redneck racist
supporters permission to hate
now what is that but peer pressure and
shaming people read that in tablet and
they think oh well I don't want to be
one of those I don't want to have
permission to hate I don't want to be a
racist redneck Yahoo and so they're
shamed out of or the objective the goal
is I would hope that nobody was fool
enough to read that and think oh I
better not support Donald Trump but the
goal of it was to shame his supporters
out of it and this is something that
goes on it it it manifests itself in all
kinds of forms one of of course the
primary vehicles for this peer pressure
and shaming is the whole concept of hate
speech now hate speech really it's
pretty straightforward if somebody is
speaking hatefully and saying that
you're a terrible person you ought to be
killed you ought to be beaten up but
that's pretty hateful but hate speech as
a concept hate speech as something that
ought to be a consideration in
determining who gets a platform and who
doesn't is an entirely spurious fiction
an invention of the left in order to
silence those with whom it disagrees in
order to silence us that's what hate
speech is all about I was speaking a
couple years ago at cowp University in
San Louis oiso wonderful little town and
very nice crowd and some very good
questions at during the presentation uh
at one point I said that there was ex
actually restriction on the freedom of
speech on the calpo campus and people
said what no what are you talking about
you racist bigoted islamophobe that's
not
true and I said well take the take me as
a case in point I've written all these
books I've written a biography of
muhammmad I've written a guide to the
Quran several studies of jihad from
various
angles I guarantee you I said to the
students that the point of view that I
represent is not discussed in your
classes on Middle East studies or Islam
and if it is it is is only discussed in
order to be dismissed if not reviled
outright and a young lady said oh no no
no you're wrong we did discuss your
books we did discuss your work in a
class that I just
took and I said oh that's very
interesting what was your conclusion and
she said hate speech is not free
speech that was the first time I heard
that you ever heard that hate speech is
not free
speech this is an increasingly common
slogan
that is going to be used and is being
used right now to shut us down what the
young lady at calp was saying was that
she had supposedly read my work and
decided that it was hate speech and that
hate speech in and of itself does not
enjoy the protection that the freedom of
speech ought to be given that hate
speech is not speech that we ought to
respect even to the extent of saying I
may disagree with what you say but I
will defend to the death your right to
say
it and so I said okay that's very
interesting I asked the young lady the
this following question then who gets to
decide because I don't think what I'm
doing is hate speech unless the Quran is
and I quote
it
but you think it's hate speech now which
one of us has the right to determine
what's hate speech what governing
authority to whom should be entrusted
this governing Authority so that we know
what hate speech is and Rule it out of
free speech protection and she said well
the relevant governing Authority that's
not important for this discussion that
would be something that would be
determined by Congress and the
president and I asked her you really
want to give them that kind of
power do you realize that to give
anybody the right to determine what hate
speech is and silence it on that basis
is a tool of the power powerful to
silence the powerless and a tool of the
tyrants to silence their
critics and she said that's just a Hoban
argument against the
powerful and I thought oh that that now
I'm stretched because I had to remember
okay who's
Hobs and what is what does she mean by
that I haven't been to college in 30
years but of course she meant Thomas
Hobbs who wrote Leviathan I had to look
it up and Leviathan is a political
Treatise from the 17th century that
posits that the only thing that can save
us because we're all sort of brutal and
violent and selfish and vicious the only
thing that can save us from an allout
war of all against all is a strong
government that keeps everybody in line
and there are some countries you can say
that's true about but what she was
saying was that I was uh manifesting an
alarming lack of trust and that really I
ought to just relax and let the relevant
authorities determine what is hate
speech and quietly go to jail with Oleg
but
uh the thing is of course that she only
thinks that because she her position is
the dominant one that's in
power the problem that she manifests
however the problem of which she is an
example is the fact that there's a whole
generation of young people who are
growing up with the idea that there is a
concept of hate speech and that we are
it and that we are Way Beyond the pale
and ought ultimately to be
criminalized and this is happening as a
matter of fact no less a constitutional
Authority than Chris
Cuomo articulated this last year when uh
we drew we we dared to uh try to stand
up for the freedom of speech in Garland
Texas and you know of course in January
2015 uh 13 people who had dared to draw
Muhammad were murdered by Islamic
jihadis in Paris and in response to that
we thought well we have two choices when
they say we're going to kill you for
drawing Muhammad you either have to draw
Muhammad or you have to submit and say
yes you can get me to do what you want
by threatening to kill me and so you can
manipulate me into silence and slavery
and so to stand up for freedom and for
freedom of speech of course we had a uh
Muhammad Art Exhibit in cartoon contest
in Garland Texas jihadis attacked it and
and there was a great deal of uh media
coverage there for a while about it in
which at which time Chris Cuomo actually
stated that uh the First Amendment does
not apply to hate
speech and what we were doing was hate
speech and therefore it was ruled out
now actually if you read the first
amendment it doesn't say anything about
hate speech nor is there any legal thing
in United States law called hate speech
there is no such concept
because of course what's hateful to you
is not hateful to me one man's ceiling
is another man's floor everybody has a
different evaluation of what is true and
good and right and what is evil and
hateful for that matter but just the
advance of this idea that Chris Cuomo
could think a major commentator on a
major
Network even that in itself indicates
how deep the rot has gone and how far
Advanced this concept is that there is
an idea of hate speech and that we are
it now the peer pressure and shaming
advances of course by charging us with
this hate speech and recently there are
many so many examples of this I could
talk all evening I promise I won't but
there were there there's so many
examples of this where opinions that are
perfectly valid and have a claim to
truth and in an earlier insaner age
would have been evaluated on their
merits are instead dismissed as hate
speech AED as such and that is all part
of this overall initiative of peer
pressure and shaming that Hillary
Clinton told us they were going to do
one example of course is our friends the
Southern Poverty Law Center uh a group
that uh actually did work in a valid
work in the 60s for civil rights but now
has completely gone off the rails and
become a tool for the left uh the
Southern Poverty Law Center recently as
you may know uh issued a report on the
15 top anti-muslim
extremists in the United States which
included of course David harwitz and me
Frank Gaffney Pamela Geller uh many
other TW 10 or 12 others obviously and
two of the people on the list of these
anti-muslim extremists were a uh
reformist Muslim from the UK Majid naaz
and the ex Muslim from Somalia the
famous Freedom Fighter Ayan hir Ali now
this made this all very interesting
because you know Frank and David and I
and the others we're used to uh being
defamed in this way although this was a
new one to call us anti-muslim
extremists if you think about that for a
minute what does the Obama
Administration call terrorists
extremists their whole program to fight
Jihad terrorism doesn't say Jihad or
Islam because that's forbidden in the
Obama Administration it's called
countering violent
extremism so to call us extremists the
PLC is saying we are terrorists we are
the equivalent
of baghdaddy the Isis kff and Osama Bin
Laden and alaki and all the rest of them
we're just the flip side of the coin now
actually it's true David and I do plan
to fly a plane into a high-rise building
later on tonight but in the meantime I I
do think that that is an absurd
categorization but the uh what what
happened in the wake of this was was
that Majid naaz in particular because he
is uh very prominent on the left and
particularly popular Among The Atheist
critics of uh Islam and Jihad uh Sam
Harris Richard Dawkins and so on the the
uh The Atheist spokesman who have
actually spoken about it out about Islam
uh there was a petition to get Majid
noaz and Ayan off the list and of course
the implication was it was perfectly
fine for us right-wing racists and
bigots to be on it but now they had
crossed the line now what was there was
a certain touching naive to this you see
uh these these supporters of Majid naaz
and Ayan H Ali were thinking well those
13 those terrible deplorables they
belong on the list but our friends they
don't these people now they're just
unjustly maligning Majid Naas and Aon
they're taking their statements out of
context and misrepresenting them they
are claiming Gil guilt by Association
indicating that they uh have
associations with unsavory types and
they're questioning their motives and so
on well what do you think happened to
the rest of us this is just what the
splc and these other groups it's its
Allied groups have been doing to us for
years it's exactly the same thing it's
all been a large-scale effort at peer
pressure and shaming making it so that
we're toxic so that nobody else wants to
speak out in the same way because they
don't want to be toxic and the whole
idea of speaking out is stigmatized so
that everybody is mute and Silent as the
Jihad advances it's very well thought
out I really got to give him credit it's
a very skillful plan it's very clever
and very imaginative and deeply evil but
one thing you know there's always a
silver lining and the the Uproar about
Majid Naas and Ayan being included Among
Us anti-muslim extremists it woke up a
lot of people who I think had no idea
that the splc is just a propaganda
machine but it is part of this
propaganda machine that is working to
extend the peer pressure and shaming to
every honest critic who explores the
motivating ideology of the Jihad
terrorists and so we see it in all kinds
of contexts quite aside from the
Southern Poverty Law Center we even see
it at
ESPN now ESPN is where I go when I want
to not think about this but it intruded
even there of course you probably know
that Kurt Schilling the uh great
baseball pitcher was uh after his
pitching years were over he joined ESPN
as a uh uh analyst a sports analyst of
some kind I guess he probably talked
about baseball and Kurt Schilling
actually is a conservative he now has a
conservative talk show in in the uh
Boston area and he's uh he he he's got
very sound views on pretty much
everything as far as I know and he
actually dared to tweet out on his
Twitter account some statements about
Islam most notoriously one where he said
you say that only a tiny percentage of
Muslims are jihadis well only a tiny
percentage of Germans were Nazis how did
that work out for daring to say that he
was suspended for saying other things
that were outside the realm of what is
acceptable he was ultimately fired by
ESPN so apparently in order to talk
about baseball on
ESPN you have to have the right opinions
or you will be shamed out of your
job and the wrong opinions are of course
the ones that probably most of us here
hold today it is now being it's it's
being taken for granted that we
represent hate speech and it's being
extended into every aspect of
society
the ultimate goal of course is to make
everyone afraid to hold these
opinions because everyone will be afraid
of losing the job of being stigmatized
as a racist and a bigot and so on I and
of course we're so used to this we've
heard ourselves called this for so many
years but it has never been so far
Advanced into the main mainstream it is
a tremendous blow to this whole
initiative that Donald Trump was elected
president above all because it shows
that people don't just buy this offand I
actually started to get some hope you
know all summer and the all fall the
news was so Bleak the polls were so bad
and Hill was saying why aren't I ahead
by 50
points and
uh everything was so Bleak but I saw one
thing that made me just dare to hope
that things might turn out better and
that was that trust in the media was at
the lowest point it had ever been since
anybody started keeping track of this
sort of
thing and so while they are working to
shame us and to apply peer pressure to
silence us and while they are working to
label what we do as hate speech more and
more people are waking up to it and 60
million of them did not buy it and voted
for Donald Trump and so what we have now
however is a president of the United
States who commits hate speech and is
subject to peer pressure and
shaming and it's an extraordinary
position because after working so hard
to delegitimize half of the American
electorate and half of the spectrum of
opinion that Americans legitimately hold
now that opinion is in power against
their best efforts now things are really
going to get
interesting and one of the best things
actually that's come about in this
election cycle besides the election of
Donald Trump was also the Wikileaks
exposure of just what the media really
is and that's one of the reasons why the
trust in it is so very
low because you know we grew up I mean I
remember my father yelling at Walter
kronite Walter was not in the room he
was on the screen but it was just what
he was
saying and I remember
Nixon the first one
saying that he had faced bias from the
Press when he was running against John
Kennedy in
1960 now that's an awfully long time ago
and that's a lot of Elections we've all
grown up taking for granted media bias
but now what we know that it's far worse
than that I took a tour of of the an
online tour of the major news outlets uh
in the early fall and the New York Times
The Washington Post CNN
MSNBC
Politico the hill all the all all the
major names and every last one of them
had story after story after story about
what a dangerous scoundrel Donald Trump
was and stupid to boot you know there is
an inherent self-contradiction how they
classify all conservatives they did this
with George W bush too you know he was a
monkey he was a marginal idiot but he
was also an evil genius who had somehow
thwarted all their
plans while being an idiot monkey really
astonishing talents and of course Trump
it's the same way and every last media
Outlet had anti-trump anti-trump
anti-trump stories not even the pretense
of trying to be balanced news outlets
anymore not even pretending to have any
objectivity it was just all W to--all
anti-trump all the time and then it came
out in
Wikileaks George Soros George Soros
funded organizations paid for paid those
August trusted news outlets the New York
Times The Washington Post CNN you name
it they paid them for favorable coverage
of the Iran nuclear deal they paid them
for favorable coverage of the Muslim
migrant influx into
Europe they paid them for
reports on the terrible islamophobes
they probably paid for that Southern
Poverty Law Center anti-muslim
extremists list but they certainly paid
for other reports about how David
harwitz and I and others are these
terrible hateful evil people who no
decent person should have anything to do
with and so we now know this is not not
news outlets at all these are bought and
paid for propaganda
outlets and their hegemony has been
broken even if Hillary Clinton had won
they would never have the hold that they
had they will never have it again and so
we have every reason to be upbeat this
is an
ongoing initiative as I said it's not
going to go away they're going to be
continued efforts to stigmatize us
continued efforts to smear Trump as he
becomes president as he does anything
continued efforts to say that this is
just some anomaly sunspots an accident
of the Electoral College something
happened so that this Maniac got to be
president but he's still a maniac and
any decent ordinary person will think
he's a
maniac nonetheless the blades of grass
have broken through the concrete and it
can't not it can't be repaired and so
there's every reason for Hope but I will
close with uh noting what exactly it is
that we're up against what the effect of
this stigmatization really
is we have heard for decades now and
particularly after 9/11 that any honest
discussion of how Islamic jihadis use
the texts and teachings of Islam which
you can see in my guide to the Quran and
biography of Muhammad available
now any honest discussion of that is
hateful in itself bigoted racist Beyond
The Pale of acceptable discourse now
this is how this works a few years back
there was a Jihad plot against Fort
Dicks in New Jersey and a group of musl
Muslims were going to go into Fort Dicks
and shoot as many American soldiers as
possible before they themselves were
killed because the Quran promises
Paradise to Those Who Kill and are
killed for Allah it's the only promise
of Paradise in the Quran it's chapter 9
ver 111 if you want to look it up and it
says you'll go straight to paradise if
you kill and are killed these Muslims
were going to go into Fort Dicks and
kill and be killed and go straight to
paradise but they were foiled now they
were only foiled was by on a Sho string
as it happened these guys were Islamic
jihadis Islamic jihadis love death they
always tell us that they love death they
love Bloodshed they love Gore not Al and
they went to a video
store because they had their bloody
Jihad videos their beheading videos and
their bombing videos they had them on
VHS tapes and so they asked the man the
young man at the video store 17-year-old
boy they asked him to transfer their VHS
Jihad tapes to
DVD as he's doing the job he saw what
was on the tapes and he got alarmed and
he went to his boss and he said
dude I'm seeing some very weird on
these
videos should I call the police or would
that be
[Music]
racist now I should tell you these
jihadis were albanians they were
Albanian Muslims
albanians are blond haired blue-eyed
white guys so there was nothing remotely
racist about what they were doing not by
any stretch of the
imagination the idea that turning them
into the cops because not turning them
into the cops because it would be racist
was just something that had been drummed
into this young man's head all his life
that Muslims are victims and that any
movement against Jihad terrorism there's
something wrong with it and you think
that that's outlandish it's not the uh
progam very successful program of
surveillance in Muslim communities a
completely legal program that had been
challenged in court and held up to the
challenge in New York City it was shut
down by Mayor DeBlasio on the grounds
that it was hateful now what's hateful
about trying to defend ourselves against
these people if you think about it you
know how Trump is Hitler because he
wanted to keep he want he he had
proposed a temporary moratorium on
Muslim immigration now you may recall
the Hitler in 1940 he banned the
immigration of Jews so that he could
kill them and hit uh Trump not Hitler
wants to ban the immigration of Muslims
so they won't kill us those two things
are not exactly equivalent but the idea
that it's a terrible anti-muslim
thing completely obscures the fact that
he's he doesn't have something against
Muslims he doesn't have something
against brown people as the way it's
always put he does not have have some
racist agenda here because for for one
thing he's not saying let's have a ban
on Hindu or Buddhist or any other kind
of immigration of people of the same
brownness as supposedly the Muslims
are the problem is that he's trying to
address in suggesting this ban is that
there are going to be Islamic jihadis
among the Muslims who enter the country
how do you keep them out you can't tell
the jihadis from the peaceful Muslims
they don't care membership cards in
al-Qaeda so how are you going to tell
there's no way to tell to distinguish
the one from the other so you either
have mass immigration of Muslims into
the United States and more Jihad
massacres or you have a ban on the
immigration but the idea that it's
racist and hateful is just more of this
peer pressure and shaming that almost
worked with that young man at Fort Dicks
he did turn them in he decided to go
ahead and be
racist and so he saved a lot of people
from being killed but the stigma had
already worked or he wouldn't have
hesitated and the stigma is what they
are trying to apply to any and every
form of resistance to Jihad Terror that
it's anti-muslim it is hateful and
therefore it must be ruled out of polite
Society now you understand we still have
the First Amendment we still have the
freedom of
speech but we know that there are
certain things that can be said in the
mainstream and certain things that will
immediately be branded as hateful
and that is how Hillary Clinton's
program of peer pressure and shaming
works just absolutely so well and is
going to continue to do so unfortunately
despite her
defeat the upshot is however that we do
have every reason to be optimistic not
just with Trump's election but with the
breaking of the strangle hold of the
mainstream and the possibility that
truth might now actually even break
through somewhere like CNN
I'm not counting on it I suspect that
these great news conglomerate Industries
will go out of business before they
would moderate what they're doing but
the people have had enough and that is
our hope what we have is an ongoing
struggle that we have to be very aware
of and Resolute in whatever fashion that
we can be in our own sphere in life to
resist and to identify this as an
Insidious attempt at the peer pressure
and shaming to Stig ize what is a
legitimate point of view and indeed a
necessary one for our common
defense and because ultimately we do
have the truth on our side we know that
we will in the final instance be
victorious thank you very
much Robert uh could you tell us uh how
do you undo resolution 1618 that has
been signed by Hillary
Clinton well you know resolutions in the
UN are not Iron Dog but they can be
reversed they can be repealed just like
in any other parliamentary body I see so
it's not in stone in other words that
res resolution 1618 does not commit the
American people at this moment in time
no no certainly not and uh one thing
that I think the Trump Administration
ought to do is make sure that the United
States is clearly and explicitly and
defiantly on record defending the
freedom of speech at the UN because in
fact uh they're going forward with this
1618 resolution and making it larger and
bigger all of the states at at the
United Nations so it's something perhaps
uh Hillary probably would have tried to
implement it all you needed was a ninth
Justice who was a foe of the freedom of
speech the four left justices on the
court right now have all gone on record
saying they would be in favor of various
kinds of restrictions on the freedom of
speech and one more thing and so all you
needed was one more we really dodged a
bullet here all you needed was one more
to say hate speech is not free speech
and does not enjoy first amendment
protection and actually codify that in
the Supreme Court decision and that
first amendment would have been dead uh
one more question there's 1.7 billion
Muslims according to your very very
thorough research what percentage would
you say of that 1.7 billion are a threat
to the world are a threat to the world
yes to to our way of life to the Western
world there's no way to answer that
question but just off the top of your
head the reason why is because the
teachings about Jihad Warfare against
unbelievers and subjugating them under
the rule of Islamic law which denies the
freedom of speech and the freedom of
conscience and equality of Rights of
women and so many other things all that
is in Islamic law it is not negotiable
it's not some extremist opinion it's
basic mainstream ordinary Islam those
who tell you otherwise are lying now the
that said does every Muslim believe that
does every Muslim is every Muslim bound
to carry those things out no absolutely
not just like uh in in any other
religious tradition there are some
people who are very serious about it and
some people who aren't and every shade
every gradation in between so you have
uh in the Catholic Church contraception
is illegal is immoral according to the
pope but surveys show most Catholics
practice contracep does that mean that
the Catholic church does not teach that
no it really does but most Catholics
don't pay attention now in Islam it's
the same thing does Islam in all its
various sects and forms teach Jihad
Warfare against unbelievers yes does
that mean every Muslim is a Jihadi
absolutely not many many Muslims don't
know about that don't care about that
are never going to put it into practice
they would rather live a comfortable
life then go blow themselves up but
they're not going to lift a finger to uh
stop the guys who are blowing themselves
up because they know that it's in
there who has the mic I do um this is a
question I wanted to ask an couter and I
probably would have gotten a flip funny
answer but I'd actually rather ask it to
you which is what would you like to see
happen to the UN in a Trump World I'd
appreciate your perspective on that what
would I like to see happen to the UN in
a Trump World was that the question well
can you imagine the mushroom
Cloud uh seriously what I would like to
see happen to the UN is that uh
certainly the US should withdraw all
funding from it and evict it from the
United
States uh we can't shut it down because
there are a few other countries in it
but we can keep it out of New York and
the United States in general they can go
to Geneva and they can raise their own
money it's a it's a propaganda arm for
the global Jihad for the OIC it's a
propaganda arm to hit Israel above all
and so we have no business allowing our
Ally to be subjected to this or to
continue with this pretense that it's
something that actually brings anything
good to the world it
doesn't Carl Robert thank you I first of
all want to thank you profusely for all
of your efforts in the cause of Freedom
thank you for your courageous
efforts thank
you now uh could you kindly explain or
expound upon and assess the following
two assertions that we hear all too
frequently one of them we are not at war
with Islam and the second one the
ideology of takfirism is an existential
threat to the United States well the
ideology of takfirism is kind of an
incoherent thing to say because takir is
the uh practice of one Muslim group
declaring that another Muslim group is
not Muslim and can therefore be killed
as Heretics or apostates because heresy
and apostasy carry the death penalty in
Islam so many of the groups that are
more entrenched in uh uh holding on to
their wealth and power like the Saudi
government uh the
Iranians uh they declared groups like
Al-Qaeda they call groups like Al-Qaeda
and Isis tfues which means these are the
people who are saying that the rest of
us are not Muslims and trying to kill
but that doesn't mean that of course the
Saudis are the Iranian the Iranians say
it CU they're Shiites and the al-Qaeda
and Isis people are sunnis but in any
case the the nobody should get the idea
that the takfiris or that is Al-Qaeda
and Isis and the other Jihad groups are
the only people who hold to the view
that there should be Warfare against
unbelievers this is as I said standard
Islam kill them wherever you find them
is three times in the Quran chapter 2
191 489 and 95 if you want to look it up
chapter 9: 29 says to wage war against
the Jews and Christians and subjugate
them as inferiors under the rule of
Islamic law paying a special tax uh all
these things are in basic Islam so if
somebody says that it's just these Tu
Fury groups Al-Qaeda Isis bah
Haram Abu saaf and so on that that
practice this that's just completely
false on the face of it it's taught by
all the mainstream sects of Islam and
the first question we are not at war
with Islam that also is uh sort of a
false statement I mean we're not at war
with Islam but large portions of Islam
are at war with us and the Muslims who
are at war with us they point to the
Quran and Sunnah the example of Muhammad
to justify what they're doing and make
recruits among peaceful Muslims and
unless and until we recognize that we're
never going to get anywhere the Obama
Administration in 2011 outlawed any
honest discussion of the motivating
ideology of the terrorists it actually
is forbidden if you join the FBI today
which I would not recommend maybe when
Trump is in but not right now if you
join the FBI today and you say I want to
go into counterterror you will not learn
anything about Islam anything about
Jihad even though that is the largest
global threat the US faces you will hear
about right-wing extremists and militias
and Constitution groups but there is
official policy of the Obama
Administration no mention of Islam and
Jihad in connection with terrorism the
upshot is that our agent are completely
unequipped to deal with what they are
seeing with the jihadis you can't defeat
an enemy you don't understand and they
get the Intel about these people and
they don't know what it
means the sarv brothers who blew up the
Boston Marathon Russia reported them to
the FBI they said these guys actually
Tamarin the older one he went to Jihad
groups he joined Jihad groups in
dagistan now this was right around the
time that the FBI under orders from John
Brennan and Obama were erasing all
mention of Islam and Jihad from
counterterror so they get the Intel from
the Russians that says these guys join
Jihad groups right when the United
States is binding itself as official
policy to the idea that Jihad is benign
nothing to worry about nothing to be
concerned with how could they possibly
have followed through on that Intel it
went against the stated policy of the
administration and so the marathon blew
up and so we have to understand that
Islam to a tremendous degree is at war
with us and that if we don't realize
that it's just going to get worse but of
course Trump he made a big uh deal
during the campaign of the fact that he
would say that there was a threat from
what he called radical Islam it's
actually mainstream Orthodox ordinary
Islam but even saying radical Islam
after these eight years of denial and
willful ignorance is refreshing and one
would hope that he will change the
institutional culture in the FBI and the
CIA and Homeland Security and all the
rest of them it's drastically
needed who has the mic yes sir hi um so
I go to a high school where 99% of the
students their parents are lobbyists or
work in government I guess you could say
I live in the swamp um so I recently
recently wrote something reflecting on
the results of the election and as you
can probably imagine it was pretty
positive um and also as you can imagine
I received a slew of peer pressure and
shaming as you'd say I was told that
Trump validates the KKK and white
supremacy and I said no the only reason
they lashed on to the campaign is
because of the media's lies and
character assassination that told
everybody that Trump was racist even
though that's not the case um however
what other advice would you give to
someone like me who lives in the midst
of all those people to defend uh myself
against such
claims I think that mockery is awfully
uh awfully
undervalued and that uh there's a
tremendous potential for it particularly
on college campuses I didn't quite hear
everything that you were saying are you
in a college right now or high school
high school okay even better same thing
really at this point uh the colleges are
high schools and the high schools are
middle schools and so on but the
uh Muslim groups I don't actually know
about high school but I know that when
you get to College you'll see the Muslim
groups or
who the the the anti-israel groups the
students for justice in Palestine and so
on they uh make a great show of their
victimhood and their grievance theater
is always featured on campuses
so for example they have uh Israeli
apartheid awareness week and they build
a wall and have a checkpoint and you
have to go through the mock IDF Soldier
to get to your class and it's supposed
to show you how terrible Israel is well
you know we can have a lot of fun with
that kind of thing if we turn it around
on them and have for example you know
they have Islam Awareness Week well why
don't we have quoran awareness week and
put up uh kill them wherever you find
them and uh if you fear Disobedience
from your wife beat her and all these
things from the
Quran and they'll say how could you have
this terrible islamophobia well it's
just the Quran I thought you wanted us
to be aware of
Islam and you you play their
contradictions back on them you know
they talk about uh being feminists and
being in favor of women's rights and yet
they are in bed with and in League with
the most misogynistic and uh absolutely
violent towards women ideology on Earth
so you have a a a honor killing victim
awareness week and put the pictures of
the young attractive women who have been
killed by their fathers or their
brothers for not wearing the hijab they
have actually they have hijab week now
on campuses and I'm seeing that all
these non-muslim girls are wearing the
hijab to show solidarity with the poor
Muslim girls who are yelled at for
wearing hijab by racist bigoted
islamophobic Trump supporters and well
what about all the girls that have been
killed for wearing hijab I can give you
a long list and give you pictures of
them
and what about them do they have any
rights can we have an awareness week for
them and you're just what you you don't
care about these women it's only those
women and so on you see what I mean that
you have to in first place have a very
thick
skin and be ready for to be called
everything that there is and understand
that this is their tactic to shame us
out of doing what we're doing but you
bring it back on them and shame them for
their own contradictions and hypocrisy
okay we have our last question here and
then we're going to take a 10 minute
break why are you so racist no that
wasn't my question uh my observation
first of what you last said there are
student groups working on colleges
planning just that Saudi Arabia a partti
week and planning to do Street Theater
with gays hanging from an Iran week but
the uh the question now if I can
remember it uh was uh about uh changing
the uh culture in our security services
I know people from the intelligence and
FBI community on a personal level they
are highly aware of this but their
investigations cannot be geared that way
how long do you think it will take after
one or two o00 on January 20th for that
to change how would go about doing it
you're absolutely right I I also know
many people in the FBI and other
agencies who are well aware of the
nature and magnitude of the Jihad threat
but they're keeping their head down down
they're doing their job they're biting
their time and so things will get better
very quickly but there are also there's
also 8 years worth of agents who don't
have a clue and who have been completely
misinformed I have a local FBI agent uh
whenever I get death threats you know he
calls me or I call him and he says
they're on it and I say yes and then we
go back to our business and nothing
happens but I talked to him now and
again and he was reassuring me the other
day last time I got a death threat and
he was saying you know I want you to
know that uh I'm well aware of this
problem with these guys that you're
tracking and also we're right on top of
the other guys on the other side and I
said what do you mean the other guys on
the other side and he said the people
Upstate the right-wing militias they're
just as dangerous as the guys you're
talking about and I thought you know do
they smoke Opium now in the FBI as a
matter of training can you imagine he
thinks right-wing when have you heard of
right-wing militias I mean 30,000 Terror
attacks around the world by Islamic
jihadis acting explicitly in the name of
the Quran Islam Muhammad since 911 how
many right-wing militias have done that
and you can say oh yes well this fellow
or that fellow or this guy had a
Confederate flag the psychopath with the
bow haircut in South
Carolina this is hardly proportionate
and hardly remotely the same magnitude
of threat but this is what they're being
taught
nowadays and they can only explore the
ideology of the one group and not the
other so we can hope and I have every
confidence now that that's going to
change and change quickly when the new
Administration comes in thank you so
much for being here